this is gm daniel neridisky we are
watching the world champion magnus
carlson facing off against anish giri
from the 2021 fiji world rapid and blitz
and we have a rue lopez of berlin and
will magnus really go into a berlin end
game no he will play the anti brilliant
d3 bishop c5 we have a trade
of bishops we have a trade of bishop for
knight and this is a very very common
line black gets that ruined pawn
structure on the queen side but in
return anish gets the two bishops white
castles and very often in these lines we
see opposite side castling which is so
so interesting so will geary castle
short first he has to defend that e5
pawn because carlson could chase that
bishop away from g4 and then the pawn on
e5 will lose a defender first he goes h6
bishop h4 there's queen e7 i think
anusha's preparing to castle queenside
that's going to make the game so
exciting knight b to d2 supporting the
nf3 and there he goes no hesitation gary
castle's queen side we are going to see
opposite side attacks in this game as
magnus will probably end up deploying
his queen side pawns will he go a4 he
can also go a3 and b4 pushing his chair
this is a critical moment white has to
decide how to start the queen side
attack but i think in a blitz game
black's attack is actually practically
speaking easier because all anish has to
do is go g5 and then h5 and he's already
threatening to go h4 in that position
this is really scary for white i'm not
sure about this opening choice for
magnus bishop back to g3 preemptively
and he puts more pressure on the e5 pawn
which she is threatening to capture so
the move knight d7 comes to mind or
bishop d6 it looks like anish does have
to defend that pawn white is threatening
to capture it with his bishop and notice
that the knights are defending each
other and the knight on b on d2 is
defending the knight on f3 so bishop
takes f3 is never an issue for white the
other knight could just replace its
cousin
giri thinking about how to defend that
pawn
i mean of course he could sacrifice it
and start pushing his kingside pawns but
that just seems a little bit too brazen
especially against someone like magnus
anish continuing to
continuing to think this is a big moment
bishop d6 and knight d7 is what i see i
think that is one of those moves is on
the horizon knight d7 opens up a
diagonal for the queen on e7 and there
it is knight d7 that's a typical move in
such positions and now my guess is
magnus will start to set his queenside
pawns in motion white has absolutely no
time to waste because now the stage is
set for anish to start pushing his
spawns he goes c3 so magnus preparing b4
and potentially even preparing d4 anish
before he pushes his own pawns he
decides to get his king over to b8 a
typical prophylactic move that king is a
little bit safer and there's before
magnus starting to push queen side pawns
bishop back to d6 lending more
reinforcement to the e5 pawn a4 by
carlson he's ready to play b5 and try to
tear that queen side apart and for
aneesh i think he's gonna start pushing
his kingside pawns he's got no time to
waste either there he goes g5 what a
fascinating game we we have here b5 this
is classic
opposite side castling action c5 a5
geary says no i'm not opening the queen
side magnus says oh yes you are there's
h5 now he's threatening h4 magnus going
each for himself he pushes the pawn on
the king side that obviously weakens his
own king side but it greatly slows down
the progress of black's pawns how is
anish going to respond to that is he
going to play f6 and support the pawn on
g5 or is he going to bring a rook to g8
rook d to g8 seems very logical because
if white takes the pawn on g5 with his
own pawn
that might allow black's h pawn to march
forward h4 and you can't take the pawn
on h4 because of the pin against white's
queen so there's a lot going on in the
king side here but another big decision
to be made by anish who has to decide is
he going to defend the g5 pawn or is he
going to take on h4 he does take on h4
and now he plays f6 cutting open the pin
queen b3 unpinning the knight on f3 and
getting the queen in position i think
magnus is preparing to blast open the
queen side with the move b5 to b6 that's
a pretty scary prospect for anish who is
about to do something on the queen side
hesitating there not sure which pc was
about to grab rook d to g8 still on the
cards he has to play that move at some
point in order to accumulate his own
pieces on the king side and he goes rook
h to g8 so he keeps the other rook on d8
probably for defensive purposes that's
kind of interesting i thought rook ddg8
was more natural maybe it doesn't matter
now carlson can't move the knight on d2
because if bishop takes f3 the king on
g1 is pinned maybe carlson wants to go
king h1 here just to remove that
headache but does he have time for that
this is a battle of tempe who strikes
first will magnus go b6 will he go a6
and try to create a lobster pincer
situation bishop g3 so he adds more beef
on the g file and maybe the knight on f3
is going to jump out to h4 because black
has a pretty big weakness on the f5
square so carlson could try to slow
everything down by getting his knight to
h4 bishop e6 queen a4 getting the queen
out of dodge and b6 is still very much
on the cards as white has lined up two
of his heavy pieces on the a file magnus
very very devious here anish hesitating
once again how will he keep accumulating
his pieces on the k on the king side
rook up to g4 and knight h4 is still
possible magnus can go knight h4 and
then get the other knight over to f3 and
try to slow everything down as much as
possible the downside of that is that
white is just not gonna have enough
pieces to attack on the other side of
the board
and we see the cameraman come over we
see carlson he's very very calm he
always is even in the most complicated
position as he takes a pretty long thing
here he also has to reckon with the
possibility of f6 f5 notice that the
rook on g4 is laterally pinning the pawn
on e4 and there's a queen on the other
end of that so if black plays f5 geary
might be able to forcibly push his pawn
down to f4 that would be a big deal
knight h2 kicking the rook away from g4
i think that is exactly what carlson was
afraid of now where will anish put it
rook g6 seems really natural to leave
open room on the g file for the other
pieces but maybe he'll bring it all the
way back to gm maybe he won't move it at
all maybe he'll sack the exchange
anish
taking his time here time trouble
approaching rook
and
back to g7 carlson bringing his other
knight to f3 i think that knight is
going to h4 i think that is what carlson
is settling for and he is leaving his
other knight on h2 in order to prevent
rook g4 yes knight h4 and c4 by any
sacrificing a pawn opening up the c5
square for his knight what an idea so
after d takes c4 he wants to go knight
c5 and this is exactly what's happening
knight c5 queen has to drop back to c2
now the e4 pawn is a vulnerability that
is a lot of progress there by geary he
can recapture the pawn on c4 but then he
allows the knight on h4 to jump into f5
this is exceedingly complicated i don't
know who's better but it looks like
black is an initiative here queen f7
getting the queen out of forking range
of the knight now the stage is set and
black can recapture the pawn on c4
there's b6 geary takes it he's probably
going to go a6 he does he closes down
the a-file i'm not seeing too much
action on the queen side for magnus rook
fd1 he tries to attack down the default
guillermo bring his brings his bishop
back will we see knight f5 from carlson
no he'll see rook d5 sacrificing the
exchange using the pawn on c4 as a base
and what an exchange stack this is if
giri takes and he does now knight f5 is
going to come with great effect the pawn
on d5 is super dangerous as well anisha
has to be very very accurate here brings
his bishop back to d8 targets the pawn
on b6 there's knight f5 rook g6 keeping
the x-ray exchange is anish the other
knight coming out to f3 looks like
magnus has the initiative can anish do
something against these encroaching
white white pieces but still black is
super solid here that knight on f5 could
potentially lose its base of support if
black takes on e4 and anish's idea here
is to go rook g4 and target that pawn e4
which is holding white's entire position
together magnus seems a little bit
nervous here it looks really nice for
white but white's also got a lot of
weaknesses here the pawn on b6 is weak
the pawn on e4 is weak black strokes are
still doubled on the g file the moment
that bishop moves away from g3 black is
crashing through net h4 and now rook g4
or rook g5 nope and he's dropping his
rook back and where is he gonna move it
he's gonna move it to g4 and carlson
forking the rooks with knight h6 but
down goes the e pawn and down goes the
bishop knight takes g3 this is looking
pretty good for black and bishop takes
b6 with a check and now any three
captures the knight now he's up a pawn
and white's king on h2 is incredibly
vulnerable the queen might drop down to
g4 rook b1 carlson tries to get stuff
going down the b flat bishop c5
and the d5 pawn is also hanging
carlson's position looks incredibly
flimsy here and he's down a pawn and
black is a passport on a6 so any end
game is going to be bad for black c4
defending upon d5 there goes the queen
geary's completely in charge right now
queen g4 rook b3 carlson has to defend
g3 bishop f2 not possible yet because of
the queen on c2 but something to keep in
mind that e pawn can rumble forward e4
that looks so strong giri threatening e3
magnus is on the ropes queen b2
attacking b7 geary ignores it bishop d6
now carlson could capture on b7 but
after the king moves back to a8 i think
there's going to be no way to defend g3
and if g3 falls white's whole position
collapses this looks lost for carlson i
don't see what he can do and he's
twirling the pieces around he's getting
nervous work takes b7 killing e8 now the
rook on b7 is also vulnerable white's
position is collapsing this is lost for
magnus he doesn't know what to do right
back to b3 bishop takes g3 gary's going
to win the knight on h4 it's over and
carlson resigns what a performance by
anishkiri defeating magnus with black if
you want to see more videos like this
make sure to click the link that's
popping up on your screen right now this
was gm daniel nerdisky hope you enjoyed
this incredible game between magnus and
anish geary
[Music]